so hello hello everybody i want to say
good morning but it's not morning
everywhere so i'm just going to say
hello and welcome to ask doc live
my name is rebecca dukes kozak and i am
going to be your host for the next two
hours
of empowering information
i am joined today with my co-hosts ruth
ellen sanchez dr judy reynolds and
heather bowen as we bring some amazing
information to you so if you are here
live with us make sure that you have
that chat box
open so that you can see all the and
valuable information that is in that
chat
while we are going through the program
so our co-hosts are going to be putting
some information in there that will help
you be able to
check you know what dr wallach is
talking about and some resources as we
go through the program now i do want to
say that the content of this program is
to provide educational information only
on the importance of nutrition
and supplementation but it's not really
supplementation and doc's going to tell
us about that
the food supplies around the world are
null and void
and empty of what the body really needs
in order to not just survive but
actually thrive and that's what our
bodies are designed to do
is to thrive and in this program we will
be sharing nutritional options
that are available
to help fill those gaps and provide you
the foundation that your body really
needs now the fda requires us to let you
know that our products are not meant to
treat prevent diagnose or cure any
diseases and this program is not meant
to take the place of your primary care
physician
but our target doctor dr joe wallick has
been instrumental in suing that
wonderful establishment with of nine
victories so these victories have all
led to the addition of vital nutrients
added to foods and allowing the
distribution of information proven by
science folks to be factual with the
essential need of supplementation
against disease now we bring good news
so the genetic theory which many of us
have been told we have a genetic
condition and that's just the way it is
there's nothing we can do about it well
there's a science called epigenetics and
epigenetics has proven that genetic
theory
incorrect
incorrect folks with epigenetics you are
empowered as an individual to make
choices
that can actually divert or even make a
u-turn on your health journey and that's
what we're going to be sharing with you
today
so any testimonials that are shared on
this program are that of the individual
they are not solicited we have so many
folks that are just so grateful for the
changes that
they have been able to make and their
health that they voluntarily come on and
we don't even know they're coming on to
share that information with us now we
are honored to be have to have with us
one of the founding fathers of the
science of epigenetics dr joel
wallach dr wallick welcome to ask doc
live
well thank you rebecca thank you team
for being here and all the great work
you
do i just um been awestruck by all the
good stuff you do and we're very
appreciative
and of course um we have a big victory
in our hands we have a big victory in
our hands right now as we speak okay and
i'm going to kind of flash this up here
okay
uh
you can see me with one of my babies
that's a cute little baby dr wallace
looks exactly like me
uh no
maybe
but he's really cute so are you
i don't know about exactly like you but
what you found
okay well um
because of my background
i i kind of look at things differently
than everybody else i i don't
take
at
um
which i say i i don't take everything
that the medical system says or the
pharmaceutical system says uh for a
hundred percent uh because their
goal is to treat symptoms and they do a
very good job of treating symptoms
but they rarely get to the bottom root
cause i'm going to go back to the 1950s
and there's a new
uh
which i say there was a new
class of diseases in town because that's
when they officially came out with the
concept of autoimmune diseases where the
body's attacking itself okay 1950s we're
talking about irritable bowel syndrome
lupus fibromyalgia or psoriatic
arthritis
we're talking about those kinds of
things also
they threw in ms multiple
well multiple sclerosis and i'm alerted
to this because
just about 10 days ago
there was a big headline on every news
thing on tv every newspaper i mean it
was like crazy
okay the radio the internet
that
each year in america now i hope you're
sitting down each year in america
we spend just on pharmaceuticals just on
pharmaceuticals for ms multiple
sclerosis 85 billion dollars in the
united states alone
85 billion
okay there's 400
people in the united states right now
currently with ms and they spend 60 000
a year farther
for their pharmaceuticals to deal with
their symptoms
around amounts to 85 billion dollars a
year
well it turns out
that um when i went and really dug up
all the stuff
on lupus because i've had very few lupus
patients come to me
okay
um
i take that back not lupus patients but
ms multiple sclerosis patients had very
few ms patients come to me and so i
really didn't have an urge to do a whole
lot about it
but here we go when that when that came
out i say okay who's paying for all that
you are because your insurance rates go
up to pay for that
so that those people with ms don't have
to pay extraordinary amounts because
it'll just drop the insurance and so
they keep the ms patients paying for the
insurance by raising your insurance
rates
okay and so that's how they cover it
85 billion a year 400 000 ms patients
and they're being just treated
symptomatically well it turns out do we
already have
experience in treating
what's going on with the ms patients the
ms patients have a minimum of three
different diseases
they have three different diseases all
of which are simple nutritional
deficiency diseases but the the thing
that goes on with those nutritional
deficiencies you might have five or six
clinical
symptoms in each one of those and some
of them you can get as many as 25
clinical symptoms okay
and so this is i think what's confusing
the medical system the pharmaceutical
industry but they're happy 85 billion is
not bad
okay
and so what is going on here well it
turns out
that
they have osteoporosis of the skull
they have a gluten issue
and they have
multiple deficiencies
as a result which result in diabetes and
hybrid pressure and liver problems and
lung problems and so forth
this all is clumped together
as
ms multiple sclerosis what about the
demyelination of the brain well it turns
out
when you have a gluten problem you
cannot absorb cholesterol and doctors
say don't eat cholesterol stay away from
cholesterol little plaque you put plaque
arteries and they'll put you on statin
drugs and right now i'm investigating to
see
what the percentage of people who have
ms are on statin drugs
because that would explain a lot
okay because
um
your brain weight
is um
okay 75 percent of the white matter of
the brain okay the myelin the insulation
material on your nerves in the brain
is cholesterol
uh your brain contains
20 of the cholesterol in your body
okay your brain produces cholesterol
every second of every day because this
is what the and of course when they look
at the dna demons
when they look at the demyelination okay
going away of the myelin in the brain ah
there it is that's that autoimmune thing
the myelin is going away in the brain
well that's because i got them on all
these statin drugs i have to find out
when did these statin drugs come out
maybe it was the 1950s
i think it probably was
okay and so that's when
the ms really spiked okay
and so
let's look at that
every symptom
that they have
i've already written about because
they're all nutritional deficiencies
things so
uh they need to get
a certain set of books and then i'll
tell you the products uh it's all in
your head okay just about everything
that's right here the cover people with
ms multiple sclerosis have you got
ringing in the ears they have vertigo
they have
um
the equivalent of um
let's see here
dysphagia that's a big issue with them
swallowing uh problems dysfunction
and
then they have stuff going on with their
respiration they have stuff going on
with their bowels they have stuff going
on with the skin obviously they have
memory problems and so forth
okay it's all in your head 25 different
diseases and almost all of those are
found in
ms multiple sclerosis
then
um and 20-year update
on
dead doctors don't lie
of course we had the book and the cd and
the audio cassette tape and the cd we
sold 600 million copies it's in nine
languages dead doctors don't lie
the new set it's a set it's a the book
the the truth about nutrition and it's a
cd and a dvd you cannot buy just the
book or the just the cd or just the dvd
you have to
um
purchase the entire set
and if you buy 10 sets we'll give you a
10 discount on each set so to save 100
bucks okay so that's cool
and it goes into the nutrients necessary
to prevent those problems and then of
course they need the book
wallace cooking without the bad foods
this is 300 pages
of a three-year research project with
three professional chefs up in canada
300 pages of gluten-free and fried food
fruit fried food
free cooking
okay which is what is necessary here
and then of course as you pointed out
the science of epigenetics
okay uh the science of epigenetics that
represents my thesis that's in the
smithsonian institute as a national
treasure there's a 25 million dollar
grant from national institutes that held
for 10 years study i did 20 000
autopsies and showed there were no
january transit diseases that's why my
thesis is in the smithsonian institute
the new ones in the in the
uh still in the box and still wrapped in
the cellophane
my thesis published by w.b saunders
publishing company where they publish
all the medical textbooks sells for 25
000 each now if they're beat up you can
get them for
you know if they're really beat up you
get them for 1500 to three thousand
dollars each if they're in fair
condition you get them for
five thousand to eight thousand dollars
each if you get them in good condition
they're eight thousand twelve thousand
dollars each but after that you gotta go
for the new ones well nobody's gonna
spend twenty five thousand dollars for a
home
remedy book
and so we came out with epigenetics it
turns out they created a new science
called epigenetics which has replaced
the science of genetics
there are no genuinely transmitted
diseases there are no autoimmune
diseases and again the autoimmune
concept came up in the 1950s when
doctors couldn't figure out
um
why penicillin wasn't working on ms and
all that kind of stuff
so they came up with oh autoimmune and
of course
you can contact your youngevity
associate uh preferably right now the
ones
that are here here with us okay
um
you can get this uh it's our
what do you call it sir educational
brochure
no this is an educational brochure okay
okay it has color pictures of the covers
of my 21 books that i published all
about sellers okay
it has colored pictures in a two or
three paragraph description of what's in
each book
okay
and so it covers every health subs you
can think of every health subject you
can think of we do have a new item on
here this is very first one um it's one
of these flash drives this flash drive
has 10
um video presentations and 43 audio
uh
presentations on there and it is flying
out the door okay this this is the
um
right up here
okay is that flash drive
and if you're a techie you know what a
flash drive is you put it on your key
chain you put on a little thing around
your neck it's about the size of a
little cluster of grapes with five
grapes on it kind of thing
and so i really urge people to think in
this direction here if you know somebody
in your
church family your temple family your
workplace your home they might be your
barber
they might be
somebody who works in a gas station they
may be somebody who
works in the bakery or whatever they're
all over the place
85 billion dollars in
pharmaceutical costs each year in
america just on ms patients no way okay
so it turns out if everybody does
everything right i think within three to
six months we can get rid of ms in
america and it will be the guiding light
and then it'll take another couple of
months to get rid of ms in the world and
i'm so excited because we already have
like these four different books that
cover everything that needs to be
covered
and we're going to work on you know
right now they can get that set of the
books
the truth about nutrition and the cd and
the dvd goes along with it it's all in
your head uh dr well is cooking about
the bad foods and then epigenetics those
four books
will give you everything you need to
know
okay and of course we have the products
are you just contact
us here
through rebecca and her team
and we'll get you on there you pay
wholesale prices if you get on auto ship
i will pay the shipping uh we're trying
to make this as cheap as possible my
goal
is to instead of um these um people with
ms paying six thousand dollars a month
for pharmaceuticals to get it down to
about depending on their body weight 300
to 500 a month for their supplement
program i don't like that word
supplement program but for their
essential factor program okay
they will
get rid of their ms well like you're
you're claiming a cure yeah i think i am
okay and i'm the guy who got rid of
uh let's see here i got rid of um
gabriel so it's supposed to be one of
the most terrible birth defects ever i
found the first non-human case of it got
it published
and freaked everybody out i got fired
from
nasa i was working with the
primate colony uh in nasa at the
europeans primate center in atlanta
georgia
at emory university and they fired me
when i said it wasn't genetic because i
found a non-human
with it and the monkey and then i got
permission to do a biopsies of 24 other
baby monkeys they all had it because
some behaviorists
in the colony um he decided they were
getting too much vitamins and minerals
and they needed more carrots and onions
so he took away all their monkey pellets
and and gave the mothers the
uh the um
just carrots and tomatoes and beans and
things like that and the next round of
babies all had
cystic fibrosis okay
and then for 25 years i couldn't do
anything about it because the medical
doctors kept blocking me
okay and so what happened was i finally
started going to federal court and as
you pointed out at that point i had nine
victories in federal court jonathan
emory a great great attorney who has
done that i paid for that out of my own
pocket there was no grants
that it would cost a pretty penny but it
got it done
and then next was muscular history you
don't hear about
you don't hear about scissor bros
anymore you don't hear about muscularis
anymore we gave jerry lewis a dozen
charts
marvin rob a u.s marine who is working
with me on that project
in idaho and utah
and um
we found the cause prevention and cure
for muscular history gave it to jerry
lewis jerry lewis contacted the doctors
of a dozen of these kids who had been
cured you know some getting very brave
there okay and uh sure enough
um
he he got excited and he took
a dozen of those charts to the
musculature association and he had
raised two billion dollars for them over
20-year period in the telethon they
fired jerry lewis and shut down the
telethon because they didn't want to
believe that it wasn't genetic
they fired jerry lewis and and shut down
the telethon that's why you haven't
heard about him
for the past 10 years
isn't that crazy
then as a spinoff
benefit
suddenly now suddenly death syndrome
isn't there anymore you don't hear about
that anymore
and doctors had the false beliefs that
mothers were sleeping and laying on
their babies and crushing the babies
okay if something like 400 to 500 a year
would die in the united states from
cinema death syndrome
or maybe it was a month i know it was a
lot but at any rate um
when we when we started
one of my lawsuits was forcing
the formulators to put these nutrients
in infamil and similac and the other
baby
food formulations
and as a benefit which i wasn't planning
on suddenly some of the death syndrome
disappeared i made him change the name
to crib death because 99 of the babies
that died of sediment death syndrome
died in the crib they weren't in bed
with the mothers they weren't crushed to
death by their mothers
doctors just said that because they
didn't know what killed them well is the
hypertrophy cardiomyopathy heart disease
it's the same thing that kills these
young athletes
uh 500 to a thousand a year in america
die from the sudden heart death in these
young athletes and of course i have two
cds to deal with this
let's see here
dead athletes don't lie
you need to listen to that one and uh
exercise supplementation suicide
you got to take your 90th century
nutrients if you're going to exercise
you got to take your 90 cents of
nutrients if you're going to get up out
of bed in the morning
and you'll add 25 to 50 healthy years to
your life
equally or maybe even more important
you'll add 25 to 50 extra healthful
years to the life of your kids and your
other loved ones there are no autoimmune
diseases there are no autoimmune
diseases there are no genetic diseases
i've proven it in court at great
personal financial costs
and so i have the right to say these
things because i'm the guy that spent
the money to get it proven in court
so with that i'm going to turn it over
to you
because i am excited
um we can start right now because these
books are available the products are
available right now
i personally do not get paid by
youngevity i don't get a single penny
from youngevity
and it's one of those things where i
make my living by selling books so
please buy the books
yes you can go to askdoclive.com
and we do have some links to some of the
most popular books but you can also go
to dot d r j wallick and wallach folks
is w
a
l l
c
h
dot com
that's d r j
wallach.com and you will find all of dr
wallach's publications that he has put
out coming directly from his publication
company
um so that's how he gets supported and
the fact that he is bringing this
information to us
at no charge to us which we greatly
thank you for dr whiley we appreciate
you so
much
um
jonathan emord is is amazing he's doing
some great things yeah he's a giant he
is a giant
he is a giant and i encourage all of you
to look for his name jonathan emord
e-m-o-r-d
so
dr wallach you know you having this
information about ms is so timely i had
um
one of my coaches come to me with a
client who has ms
so this information is going to be
valuable in being able to share this
with her which is what i encourage all
of you that are watching this program or
on live with us
we put this resource together so that
you can use it to help empower others
in being able to take control of their
own health in a more natural way folks
we are not chemical deficient
which is what pharmaceuticals are
we are nutrient deficient
so
for me it's common sense
you replace those nutrients and make
sure that the body is getting them each
and every day
and you're not going to need those
chemicals
at least not as many for some folks
so
well here's here's what i'd like people
to do i mean
number one this is
recorded and it's just posted right so
people can watch this over and over and
over
and so what people need to do
whether they are interested in ms or any
other quote autoimmune disease unquote
or they're interested in just getting
the truth out there and saving
themselves a lot of money on their
insurance costs because
85 billion dollars a year for
pharmaceuticals just for one disease
it's not really an autoimmune disease
okay
what i wanted to do is go to their local
news
radio stations their tv stations or
newspapers their churches
and say hey we need to get this
information out there
and um you know you can interview
wallach you can look at what's been
posted here by rebecca and her team
right away and get some sense of what's
going on here
and you know if we get you know
one or two
newspapers out of every state if we get
radio stations out of every state if we
get one or two tv stations out of our
state getting this information out there
we're going to save more and more people
and i guarantee you we will drop that
expenditure from 85 billion a year my
goal is to get it down to about
say
um
20 30 million a year
okay
big drop okay and then after a year
it'll go to zero
because it's not a genetic disease is
not autoimmune it's a collection it's a
collection of nutritional deficiency
diseases now one of the secrets is here
uh people the diagnosis of
ms occurs between the ages of 20 and 50.
the average age of diagnosis is 30. so
it's not a birth defect it's not
something somebody's born with it sort
of appears later
and they've been eating gluten and
oatmeal for breakfast and not taken
uh are essential factors for 25 30 years
and so suddenly now
all this stuff is happening
and
your doctor says oh you have an
autoimmune disease called
ms multiple sclerosis
and of course they could put in
wheelchairs um they get tingling in the
hands and the feet
uh that's the skull squeezing the spinal
cord peripheral neuropathy
okay you get demyelination
of the white matter the brain well
that's because they're on statin drugs
so lower cholesterol and they're
because their doctor's instructions are
avoiding eating cholesterol
um 75 percent of the brain weight is
cholesterol 20 of the total cholesterol
in the body which is which is made by
every cell in the body cholesterol is
made by every cell in the body because
it's an essential nutrient
95 percent of ed erectile dysfunction
is caused by a deficiency okay of
cholesterol uh testosterone
is 95 by weight cholesterol estrogen
progesterone 95 by weight is cholesterol
and so when women have all these
troubles going through menopause guess
what it's because they're trying to be
good and listen to their doctor and stay
away from cholesterol and take statin
drugs
don't eat eggs oh my god it's got
cholesterol in them
don't don't eat dirt don't eat dairy
don't eat dairy well
dairy what's the first food rebecca tell
me what's the first food of a whale a
porpoise a wombat a kangaroo an elephant
lies in tigers and bears human beings
giraffe what's the first food
puppies milk
milk it can't be bad it's the perfect
food
that's right
that's right it's it's amazing dr
wellick um i have a client that is a
cattle rancher in montana and his doctor
told him to stay away from beef
and i'm like
like you're gonna listen to that one
he's like yeah no i'm listening to the
doctor
yeah and you go back to the bible days
you go back to the bible days
who were all the people who were the
followers of moses who are the followers
of jesus who are the followers of the
apostles
they were
farmers
and and herdsmen they had cattle herds
and goat herds and camel herds
uh okay and
these were
simple farmers these are not academics
at universities and dealt with nothing
but books and paper they were dealing
with manure and milk and all that kind
of stuff and feeding the animals and
butchering the animals and eating meat
and drinking milk and eating making
cheese because they didn't have
refrigeration so how would they save the
milk they turned it into cheese which
lasted a couple of months
okay and if they were live near a cave
they could put the cheese in the cave
and last a year kind of stuff
but um they found a way to
turn liquid milk which would go bad in a
few days if they didn't do something if
they didn't drink it
they turned it into cheese
they were also the first ones to come up
with salt
okay when you do something good in the
old days what did they say to you you
are the
salt
of the earth
you're the salt of the earth if you did
something good salt is very very good
salt is not bad for you any doctor who
said don't take salt
don't eat dairy stay away from
that sort of stuff you need to
have their license taken away and put in
jail
yeah it's
you know
as you look back in history dr wallick
and and you have brought this up many
times
when something is being broadcasted as
being bad
it's like that's the pivot point for so
many different things starting when it
comes to poor health
when they went low fat
removing
you know natural fats
removing salt from the diet
adding all these grains
every single one of those events
have created more and more
income for the pharmaceutical companies
and the medical doctors and the medical
the medical establishment yeah
it's it's nuts and in the comments here
rhonda said that you are the best and um
most amazing doctor thank you i love
this show many thanks and love
i have a customer with ms and will
definitely share so thank you so much
rhonda we appreciate it thank you rhonda
yes yes
and this page that you have with with
ms we need to have them talk to us every
week and we'll walk them through this
and they're going to be an example
and you know like i'm going to come up
with um an overview it's probably going
to start out as a
like a cd or something like that
as an overview of this whole thing but
right now again
uh the books
um
the truth about nutrition is the book
the cd the dvd
uh this is the book
um let's see here it's all in your head
it's the book dr long's cooking about
the bad foods and it's the book
um
epigenetics now those four books
and the cds and dvds that go along with
them will
eliminate
from earth
a disease called ms multiple sclerosis
and we're going to kind of work on
consolidating that and this could
probably start out as a cd or something
like that because that's easy i mean
we can just take what you've already
posted here and making once you look at
making this one into a cd okay
let's do it
let's do it we can do that we have
resources dr welling i know let's make
this one into a cd because we need to
get this cd out there
and uh and and send it to every
newspaper in america and then once every
newspaper in america has it for three or
four months then we'll send every
newspaper in the world okay
absolutely so there is one question
about ms that um
rhonda has she wants to know
does
being a vegan contribute to
the possibilities of
of getting ms
yes it does because how much cholesterol
is there in the vegan diet
very little
none
a vegan is all vegetables there's no
cholesterol and vegetables
okay so your idea so you're at a high
risk
of
getting a good question ask the
population of ms patients united states
how many of them are vegans okay
because they're avoiding how many of
them are taking statin drugs because
their doctor said you'd be understanding
drugs because you have a history
three generations back somebody in your
family had a heart attack so you need to
be on statin drugs we didn't have
alzheimer's disease until the 1960s when
they came out with statin drugs again
because 75 of your brain weight is
cholesterol
and
they have created these monster diseases
to
chase a false
theory okay the false theory is that
cholesterol causes plaque arteries
that's not true it's oils that oxidize
like salad dressings and cooking oils
okay
and so
that's why they've got to go doctor
while it's cooking about the bad foods
book 300 pages
okay this is unimpeachable stuff
and so would you please
i know it's gonna take a little bit of
effort because some stuff will have to
come out of there uh you know like our
talking about let's make a cd out of it
kind of thing we'll make it happen we'll
make it happen and it'll be fabulous
doctor
thank you thank you thank you
now let's go to chad chad i see that you
are here are you able to come on and ask
your question
go ahead and unmute yourself
uh all the reason i was waiting is
because my mom is on her way and i have
to go get her some eggs and i didn't
want him to talk to me and me have to
run out to my mom
go ahead and go with your question let's
get it in
okay so
i i have psoriasis
um
and you're you
you're saying that there's no autoimmune
i think that's awesome uh 100 i hope
you're correct and i'm hoping maybe you
have an answer for psoriasis
okay now do you have a bowel problem do
you have any like constipation diarrhea
your bowel syndrome across the seed did
you have your appendix out when you're a
kid
okay
uh let's see here
do you have anything else how about
pressure diabetes gray hair i can't tell
because you're just looking at me i have
a little bit of gray hair uh
if you have one gray hair you have one
you have gray hair i have i have a few i
have a few okay um so well gray hair it
has nothing to do with age gray hair is
due to gray silver and white is due to a
particular nutritional deficiency and i
ask that it saves a lot of time in
laboratory work because if you have gray
hair i know you have that nutritional
deficiencies and that goes along with
the psoriasis because when you have
psoriasis you do have bowel problems you
don't know it but you have bowel
problems and you're not absorbing
nutrition even if you are taking you
know consciously proactively putting
nutrients in your mouth
you have to take all 90 including the
efas and the fa pluses
okay because when you have psoriasis
this skin issue
um this has to do with a particular
nutritional deficiency
okay
and um you get off of all the bad foods
and no fried foods no processed meats
oils no gluten no we buy ryan oats no um
let's see here no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet one's got to go
cause carbonation in the diet drinks
this neutralized stomach acid so you
cannot absorb minerals and cannot digest
food
and then
i want you to have three eggs for
breakfast and three eggs for dinner time
in addition whatever else you're eating
they have to be soft yolks uh they
cannot be fried or hard boiled that they
won't count you could be soft soft oil
soft sauce gram of butter i had my three
eggs this morning i had a chicken breast
with fat this morning
i had some yogurt i was gluten free and
sugar-free i also had
let's see here
[Music]
okay i think oh i had rice had wild rice
was steamed
okay yesterday morning i had uh
baked sweet potatoes with butter for
breakfast and this morning had wild rice
and so you can you can do pretty good
i'll have gluten-free pizza for
breakfast two or three times a week the
gluten-free pizza crust is made with um
let's see here
um cauliflower
yeah there you go cauliflower yeah
cauliflower rice that kind of stuff
and so um it's uh
and it has four cheeses and six
vegetables and i'll put a hamburger
patty on there i might put some
tuna fillet that's been
steamed not cooked in any oils or
anything like that or preserve any oils
i like my tuna fillets for breakfast on
top of my gluten-free pizza you know
made from cauliflower
and so forth and the grandkids love it
you know grandpa
let's have your let's have your
your pizza and they like the taste and
everything and so i'm getting them moved
in that direction they can't go to pizza
hut
okay because pizza hut doesn't have
gluten-free pizza i don't think do they
i don't think so you have one but that'd
be cross-contaminated for sure yeah
exactly
okay and so any rate um i'm very very
excited i'm looking forward to the cd so
we can have that within within a couple
of weeks or a month or so
the cd of today's show
okay we're gonna get
it out as soon as possible okay thank
you dear okay any questions sir before
you have to run um
so i should cut out it sounded like you
said i should cut out oils entirely
that's correct okay all right and the
only kind of oil you want is for your
car
not for you
all right and then uh three egg yolks no
whites no no the whites but you want the
yolk soft okay okay okay yeah no no no i
have uh you know soft scrambled and
butter
and um yeah i want you to think about it
when a chicken lays an egg
21 days later that egg hatches into a
chick that chick comes out well let's go
back if you take an egg your center
watching the hand lazy egg you grab that
egg it's still hot from the body
temperature of the hen you crack it open
and sitting on top of that yolk is a
little white spot about a millimeter in
diameter that's the chick
a little white spot on top of the yolk
that's the chick
okay so in 21 days of incubation the
chick is in there it pecks on the shell
the shell pops open the chick comes out
it has a beating heart it has lungs at
work it has a liver that works it has
kidneys at work it has digestive tract
that works it has a brain that works it
has eyes at work it has muscles and a
skeleton it has
feathers and skin
do you think that egg has some nutrition
in it
everything that's that that made that
chick was nutrition
it was in the yolk and the white of that
egg
and so any idiot that says
eggs are bad
um they need to be put in a
in a
mental institution
all right
um
and so butter is okay butter is butter
no no
butter was one of the first things that
people ate back in the bible days
okay as a way of saving milk for a few
more days
okay and so butter is good again it has
the fat soluble vitamins from the milk
in the butter
okay so butter but no oils
no oils no margarine
okay margarine is made out of oil
salad dressings are made out of oil
what i use for my salad dressing
is uh the gluten-free yogurt
because i put like creamy
um salad dressing because i make um
gluten-free
i don't make gluten-free but i put
gluten-free yogurt on top of my salads
or sometimes i'll just put our pink
himalayan salt by itself on there i
always put pink himalayan salt on myself
whether i'm putting yogurt on or not
has 78 minerals in it plus the sodium
chloride
you got to be an idiot not to take
sea salt okay or pink himalayan salt now
that's one of the first supplements that
ever came out back in the days even
before moses okay
uh salt was a big thing on the market
because people on the coast would make
it and they'd go on inland and sell it
you know inland away from the ocean
and people would use it not only for
themselves but for their animals okay
and so
uh salt has been around for a long time
and when people did something good for
their family their community their
church their temple their school when
people did good things what did their
fellow human beings call them they were
they what salts of yours salt of the
earth salt is not bad dairy is not bad
and cut out gluten
cut out gluten gluten is bad
yes nobody should be eating any gluten
zero gluten you can't have one gluten
day a month no no gluten
they'll take 25 or 50 years off your
life
thank you very much doctor i appreciate
it a lot okay let's hear from you on a
regular basis okay yes i want to hear
your story thank you sad
eat those eggs don't just deliver them
to mom okay
awesome thanks for coming on with us
today great questions
i know there's a lot of people that are
dealing with psoriasis and not knowing
what the cause is those topical creams
dr wellick
they know
they're like no no they'll just stop the
itching okay topical creams will stop
the itching and kind of maybe relieve
some of the redness but you stop taking
the topical cream within a week it's all
back okay because you haven't changed
your diet it's due to a nutritional
deficiency and people say which one is
it which one is it and
you know 25 30 years ago i used to tell
people what each nutrient was what you
know and you notice that i don't talk
about individual nutrients
uh anymore and the reason i don't talk
about individual nutrients because then
they run to walgreens they buy that
individual nutrient then i haven't heard
from them for a while so i called the
family up and said hey whatever happened
to frank i haven't heard from him in a
couple of months oh he did what you told
him and he died a month later he said
what do you mean he died did he do it i
said yeah he did exactly as he said he
took that nutrient
okay so i stopped giving him that
nutrient got to take all 90 with extra
of that nutrient but i don't tell them
that i just tell them that's why i have
secret sauces they're a secret because i
don't tell you what's in them you can
read the label
yeah you can read the label we don't
hide that from you but
the
big picture is dr wallach that nutrients
have cofactors that allow them to
synergistically work together so that
our bodies can actually utilize them
and yeah as we're regenerating
we're getting started
and one thing here that people forget
nutritional minerals either as a basic
mineral like calcium
are a cofactor like
say um vitamin a to absorb other stuff
okay so let's say
a cofactor like vitamin a or
like calcium
these things
which they say
um they
require a lot of cofactors
and they don't occur
in a uniform blank around the crest of
the earth they only occur in veins like
gold and silver
does gold and silver occur everywhere
equally no that's why there's gold mines
here and there's certain states in the
united states that have a lot of gold
like alaska there's more gold in alaska
than in one county than there is all of
california even though there's a gold
rush in california
okay and so has there been a gold rush
in missouri or kansas
no has there been a gold rush in
tennessee no
and so forth same way with canada same
way with every country in the world
there's places where there are deposits
of gold and silver and iron and that's
why they have um iron ore and mines in
certain places and if you buy a farm and
you find you have a gold mine on your
farm well you're lucked out your next
door neighbor doesn't have it okay
none of these things occur in an equal
blanket around the coast of the earth so
that's why you have to
consciously proactively
take these essential factors every day
just like you have to breathe oxygen
every day that's why we're so worried
about the environment which is a fair
thing we got to worry about the
environment because that's where oxygen
comes from
we have to make sure that our plant life
um
uh and and i have this new book coming
out this is a big piece in this new book
um why did the trilobites one of the
first successful species on earth they
had 25 000 successful species in the
trilobites
for 275 million years they were around
and suddenly they all died out almost
overnight within like
30 000 years they died out after 275
million years
25 000 successful species why they died
of hypoxia but the hippies say they died
they died of pollution well how many
cars were there
500 million years ago
uh i don't think many
we're looking at a double lot there dr
wallace yeah how many let's see here how
many human beings were there 500 million
years ago
zero none zippo nada and so but hippies
blame the disappearance of the
trilobites on the pollution
then there was a space of about 35
million years and the dinosaurs appeared
and 250 million years of dinosaurs they
were successful they had 1 200
successful species and they died out
over 30
um
thousand years
and oh what killed them hypoxia
and because of dams well there's no
people the last dinosaur died 66 million
years ago
so
where did the dams come from glaciers
moraines they dammed up the surface
water and dammed up the flow of minerals
into the swamps where the dinosaurs
lived
if they didn't live in the oceans they
lived in the swamps for the most part
okay and so they lived in the swamps but
when the when they
when the glaciers
dammed up the the food supply to the
algae and the
plants in the in the
swamps no more oxygen and so the
dinosaurs all died of hypoxia what
causes the dead zones
they're dead because there's no oxygen
in the ocean in those places why
because of dams some are human-made dams
for irrigation and hydroelectric and
some are
made by nature okay again glaciers now
the biggest dead zone in the world
is in india okay just south of the
southern border of india with the
arabian sea 66 000 rebecca 66 700 square
miles of dead zone that's bigger than uh
let's see places like maryland and
okay
okay big area yeah there's nothing there
okay why
because there's and i asked siri i just
went to syria i said siri
are there any glaciers in india and in
three seconds
um siri came back and said there's 10
000 glaciers oh my god are there any
moraines so
there's a minimum of two
marines per glacier in india so that's
20 000 dams damming up the nutrients
going into the arabian sea and that's
why they have 66 700 square miles of
dead zone in the ocean
wow
and dead zone means nothing lives there
nothing
nothing it's just sand nothing not not
and not algae not a plant not a crab
nothing
wow
that's incredible dr walik and you know
it's
here you are
an individual
started out as a veterinarian
and actually started out as a little kid
that figured out how to fix himself
and and now you've got
you know
so many answers
to
to global issues
well i'm going to give credit to the big
guy upstairs
okay
yeah
because because
a
a kid
okay a nine-year-old kid is not going to
figure this out by himself
okay and so i had to have some
guidance for why i was picked i don't
know
but um
i figured it out because i had that
guidance
and so um i kept going in that direction
and sure enough it as predictable as
gravity
awesome well doctor wallach let's go to
the next hand that's up and for all of
you that are with us today
you can go to the zoom menu options and
find that option to raise your hand and
ask your questions
now
i also want to invite you to make sure
that you get back with the person that
is invited you to this program if you
have the desire to get started on any of
the protocols that dr wallach is
mentioning or any of the products that
are mentioned here today the person that
shared this program with you
they have
a heart they had the heart to share this
information with you because they care
so make sure that you get back with them
if you found this program on your own
you are more than welcome to go to
askdoc to
dot askdoclive.com that's all together
askdoclive.com
and you will find a store there that has
all of the products that dr wallach
mentions and again
it has his most popular books and the
replays
so if you're on with us and you hear
something that you want to share with
somebody else the replays are there from
the beginning of a stock live that you
can use as a resource
to help empower others
now dr wallach
as i mentioned let's go to a hand that
is up and rad
go ahead and unmute yourself thank you
so much
for coming on with
is this brad with a b
rad
great
how can we help you sir
oh
basically i sum up on the paper just to
be prepared my weight is 180 eight is
five eight and age is 47
i've got partially grey hair
my main concern
is
breath
my lungs uh exchange gas is working for
about one third what they supposed to be
okay are you from russia
no czech republic
but i am now in england london
capital
okay
okay i apologize because of the accent i
didn't get exactly yes i know
so i have here dr wallach um weight is
okay five foot eight
age
okay
the main concern is breathlessness
his lungs are exchanging one third of
the gas that they should he also
experiences angry explosions dyslexic
and before starting on your program dr
wallach he suffered from leaky gut
now he has a number of products but
let's make sure he knows exactly how to
take them
okay good
all right well yeah this is this all
goes along with again the gluten
okay and missing nutrients
and so
rad needs to get off of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no exceptions no
wheat by ryan oats there are no such
things as gluten-free oats the gluten in
oats is called gliadin and even though
it has a different name it's still
gluten can't have it
no carbonated drinks no sugar you know
the diet drinks got to go and then 180
pounds i would like to see him on 100
excuse me two of the healthy brain heart
packs per month and full rose training
twice a day i want him to have excuse me
may i step in
uh i've got already some of your
products and i'd like to read it to what
i've got and you can adjust what i need
okay well i'm telling you exactly what
you need here because we have thousands
of other listeners who need to hear the
same program
okay so i'm saying it for you but also
for our other listeners out there okay
okay but thank you okay so two healthy
brain and heart packs from a month photo
shooting twice a day
um needs to have
that's going to deal with his lungs okay
the two healthy brain hard packs we
could call it to healthy brain
heart and lung pack okay
but um two healthy brain hard packs
um and then he needs two bottles a month
of our msm so we take three breakfast
street lunch dinner time and they
will produce
the stuff necessary for connective
tissue cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue and people forget how
much cartilage there is in lungs all the
trachea the bronchi the bronchioles are
all cartilage okay there's an enormous
amount if you take the dry weight of
your lungs and your trachea and
everything 85 percent of the weight is
cartilage
okay when you take all the water away
and so it needs that msm
and then he needs the
let's see here collagen peptides for his
immune system uh and also for his bones
and so forth he needs the um collagen
peptides a scoop of this morning drinks
with the evening drink i also want him
because he has his dyslexia thing i want
him to have
our memory effects and take three of
those twice a day he needs our synaptic
he needs three of those twice a day and
they give the brain cells what they need
to make the biochemistry to talk to
their next-door neighbor
brain cells you need three eggs twice a
day
three eggs twice a day i weigh 142 and i
have three eggs twice a day they cannot
be fried they cannot be hard-boiled they
have to be soft poached soft boiled or
soft soft scrambling butter i like mine
sauce trembling butter
and then let's see here
um i think we've covered
the lungs the heart
the
dyslexia um um um
okay let's go let's go there okay and
call us every couple of weeks so you're
gonna have a great the hair color will
come back
because hair color
um is not
losing hair color has nothing to do with
aging it's actually a red warning light
like on the dashboard of your car
so that uh when you have white grain and
silver here i ask that question
specifically because it tells me about
deficiencies of certain nutrients okay
if you have white grain and silver hair
if you have one hair coming out of your
white hair coming out of your nose or in
your mustache you have white hair okay
okay so okay red
and um
let's see here okay so do give us a call
how about
and then rad has one more question okay
oh yeah
these dress is fine you can take three
of those twice a day absolutely
okay what's your question red
oh
i am oh
i get myself extra from the pharmacy
niacin and i am taking 1 000 milligrams
three times a day morning middle day and
in the evening is that okay with your
program or it will
how did you say niacin
niacin vitamin b3
yeah no i know niacin okay yeah and we
have a niacin i take two of those um
tablets today one breakfast one dinner
time in addition to all the niacin
that's in our healthy brain and heart
pack but no nothing wrong with that
it'll help increase circulation do you
have any blood pressure issues or
diabetes
nothing do you have any ring in your
ears do you have any ring in your ears
no
any balance problems
any noisy joints any clicking or popping
in your knees or hips or shoulders
anything like that
no
okay yeah well this will take care of
you and just give us a call every couple
of weeks because people want to know
whatever happened to that uh
okay
guy
from the neighboring country of russia
thank you very much the public who lives
in the uk dr wellick there's an eco he's
a traveler
thank you so much rad for coming on and
what uh what is the website i can find
out uh this very chat i will take a
notes what i supposed to get assessed
so you'll be able to find the replay on
askdoclive.com
and since you have products already
get with the person that helped you
order those initially
they'll be able to help help you order
more
you know if you know your
customer id and login you can check out
and use the store at askdoclive.com
oh it doesn't work in uk unfortunately
otherwise
that's right
so for anybody in the united states
stock live in canada works rad i'm going
to send you a message with information
for the uk
perfect lovely thank you
all right thank you so much
bye-bye cheers
let's go right into the next hand that
is up and that's karina dr wylick we
have about four minutes before a break
karina go ahead and unmute yourself and
if you're able to come on
camera that would be fabulous as well
ocarina hello
how are you
okay how can we help you we only have
moments left so let's get to it girl i
have a couple questions for you about
products i am a um distributor newly
uh signed on and customers are asking me
a lot about the difference between the
two efas and
i tell them that they're from different
sources but they're asking why they need
both
okay
so um it's one of those things where
um
you know how many different grains are
there you know there's wheat and barley
rye and oats and rice and
and corn and so forth well the same
thing is true
with essential fatty acids okay
essential fatty acids the efas come from
seeds not not grains you know like wheat
bread rhinos but they come from seeds
uh like sunflower seeds and stuff like
that
and then the efa pluses
okay come from fish livers
okay so it has a different
um formula okay it has a different
makeup
and so
you need them both to get everything you
need
to support brain function uh to prevent
blood clots now i'm 83 years old and
i've never had a blood clot never had
any kind of those issues
because i've been taking these things
for 75 years
okay
so the ingredients both list both so i
just wanted to yeah that's why that's
why they list both
that's why the healthy brand heart pack
has both so i only weigh 142 pounds i
take three of the fas twice a day i take
three of eight pluses twice a day
i still eat my eggs and
i eat cheese and i have the babybel
cheeses for for lunch babybel cheeses
i have with mixed salted nuts
from costco's
i have like five i think six different
uh salted nuts in there my favorites of
course are the brazil nuts and the
almonds
and so um
that's my lunch
and so you know you can get everything
you need
with this with the program through
youngevity
and then
you can have a very nice
non-inflammatory
eating
for dinner i'll have steak i have lamb
chops i have
roast beef
i have
tuna fillets i have
salmon
you know i have goat meat it's all that
kind of stuff i have deer meat because a
lot of my friends do a lot of hunting so
i get a lot of venison
um
and squirrel and rabbit and all that
kind of stuff and so as long as you stay
away from the wheat by the rhine oats
and the fried foods
um you can you can eat a lot of
interesting foods you don't have to be
bored oh i'm so bored i just every day i
ate the same thing no you don't have to
i've been doing this for 75 years i've
figured out how to eat differently every
day of every
month that help you out
the cookbook that you have it's awesome
um
also one more question can i ask one
more about um is it okay yes that one
it's awesome my only complaint about
that is the index because they like
fluffy pancakes is under f instead of p
or whatever so it's hard to find the
stuff in the index but i love that
cookbook okay um so for osteo uh and the
tangy tangerine and the osteofx is it
okay to combine those powders and take
them together every day or is there a
reason you should take them at separate
times
no i take them together
perfect okay and it's fine to take them
um
all the way up until bedtime
um yeah it doesn't bother me i'd take
them you know if i'm going to go to bed
at 10 o'clock in a particular night i
might take it at 9 30 because i'm so
busy doing other things that i take it
at 9 30. um
but um it's not like it's something
that's going to rev you up like right
drinking coffee although we have a great
coffee i shouldn't say a great coffee we
have 25 different
flavors of coffee and our coffee only
costs like
anywhere from 75 cents to a buck 50 a
cup
we have the y cups we have
brewed coffee we have the ground roasted
beans and so forth
and
it's like um 14 bucks for a month supply
compared to two cups of starbucks coffee
will cost you 14 bucks yeah yeah
and um i do the probiotics too the kids
uh pack the watermelon flavor probiotics
and people are asking me about that not
being refrigerated and being dried and
are they still getting the benefits like
from do they need live probiotics well
they are live they're just hibernating
it's kind of like
it's just like um
you know when
winter time comes
and the earth dries up
um all the bugs out there go to sleep
and they hibernate and so as soon as it
rains and it warms up to optimal
temperature they wake up again and come
out of hibernation and they're not dried
anymore they wake up and start making
babies and
and so forth
so
it's a way of preserving them
without killing them it means you don't
want to be cooking them because then you
will kill them but we just air dry them
in a room with nitrogen gas
and so they go to sleep but as soon as
you get them wet and with your saliva
they wake right up
that's awesome dr welling
i am so glad that you explained that
because i've had that as well and the
way that you put it is perfect
well we are at the top of the hour let's
go ahead and take a break everybody get
up and stretch
make sure that you have plenty of fluids
if you've got our plant-derived minerals
go ahead and put a splash in there
whether it's the plain the strawberry
kiwi mens the cherrymans doesn't matter
let's make sure that we stay hydrated
with one of the best electrolyte drinks
that there are
and
it is fabulous
you can even take it straight if you
want and get her done we'll be right
back with ask doc live
all right thank you everybody i hope
that you were able to get up and stretch
and get some information
or
sorry get some new some nourishment in
your body through hydration
we are here with astoc live and my name
again is rebecca dukes kozak i am the
host of this wonderful program that we
have made available as a resource to you
now this resource
is
not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician but it is to arm
you and empower you with information
that will allow you to
choose your health journey
so many times information is well
withheld from us many times wrong
information is given
and
this information is coming from a doctor
who has done more autopsies than anyone
else i know
and it's taking all of that information
from those autopsies
all of those data points
that he
collected put it together
with formulations that are going to
benefit us and providing us the
foundation of what we need
not to
survive but actually thrive well dr
wallach are you ready to get started
oh let's go ahead and get you unmuted
i'm back
awesome awesome now for everybody that's
here on live with us go ahead if you
have a question
find that raised hand option in the zoom
menu we love to have people on with us
live asking their questions
because
you know you have a question somebody
else is going to have that question too
and
hearing the answer to your questions is
going to be able to help so many people
so we we want to make sure that we are
helping as many people as absolutely
possible
now dr wallach let's go to
one of the messages that i received and
this is coming from connie
so
connie um in
july
of last year
um fell and
she got a compression fracture in her
spine l1
she is 64 years old
230 pounds
five foot four and she knows she needs
to lose at least a hundred pounds
um the com
she woke up yesterday with pain in her
left arm she does have a high blood
pressure and she's on a medication for
that
and she's trying very hard to lose
weight she wants to know
what are your suggestions now she does
take the
90 essential nutrients gluco gel msm
ultimate daily classic d3
um
and she gave me some more information
this morning that she did go into
urgent care or emergency and they did
rule out stroke they rule ruled out any
heart problems
and they're saying that it's
inflammation
and arthritis that's causing all of her
issues
in her back and upper left side so let's
make sure you make sure she knows
exactly what to take and how to take it
dr walik
okay
well um that's good that she had all
that information collected that saved a
lot of questioning here so basically
what we want to do
at um five foot four i'd like to see her
weigh you know 1 30 so she needs to lose
100 pounds as she knows so i wanted to
have one meal a day or a keto shake it
comes in a strawberry or chocolate i
believe
and um
the keto shake is a meal replacer it's
not to be added to a meal but it doesn't
have to be the same meal every day it
could be breakfast or lunch or dinner
for two days in a row and then the next
day could be
breakfast the next day could be dinner
the next day could be lunch for three
days whatever but
one keto shake and then two of our
rebounds fourth drink at that same meal
two of our rebound they have 100
nutrients in each rebound drink 100
nutrients okay so it's not just sugar
like red bull
all right
then that's going to help her lose a
half a pound of 2 pounds a day so
realistically
we're looking at 3 or 4 or five months
she'll be down to 130 pounds
okay
um i wouldn't do any more than one meal
a day don't do two all right then for
the um
uh she needs to start out with the two
and of course she's already doing some
of this but for other listeners she
needs
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month photos everything twice a day
and it has 215 nutrients of course the
core is the 90th century so she's
getting 215 nutrients in each of those
healthy brain heart packs i wanted to
have two bottles a month of the msm
and they're gonna i wanted to take three
of those at breakfast street lunch
dinner time they're big bottles so i
should be able to do that
and
basically this will help her rebuild
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between a ray bone makes
bonus cells skin moles in the arteries
and veins and so forth
and
um let's see here
then i also want her to have
our
collagen peptides you can take a scoop
of that collagen peptides
powder and her breakfast drink a scoop
in her evening drink that'll be the big
canister not the small canister of
collagen peptides for the high blood
pressure i wanted her to get
two bowels a month of the h
well let's go two miles a month let's go
with the ultimate daily classic taylor
so let's go with the ultimate daily
classic tablets
not the ultimate classic but the
ultimate classic
daily not the ultimate daily but the
ultimate classic daily
well on the daily classic i'll do a
daily classic i'm confusing myself for
ultimate daily classic
three of those at breakfast three dinner
time and if she's on blood pressure
medication don't cold turkey off the
medication but as the blood pressure
begins to come down she can slowly
reduce medication based on the numbers
all right
and then
let's see here
for the pain
we do have the cm cream and our trauma
oil i prefer that to be used topically
as opposed to
you know taking things like
uh cortisone and prednisone because it
actually causes
minerals to be taken out of the bones
okay so it's kind of a negative thing
they'll relieve pain but also it's a
negative long-term use it causes more
fractures okay so i think we covered
everything there
um with the
fracture
uh oh it wouldn't hurt vitamin d3 three
of those twice a day two bottles a month
and also which i think she's already
doing and then um it wouldn't hurt for
her to also take
an ounce
of our cal toddy twice a day she can
take an ounce of breakfast on to dinner
time it'd be two parts a month that's
gonna give her a little extra
um
i shouldn't say a little that's gonna
give her a considerable amount of extra
calcium
to help rebuild those bones in her back
and her neck and her hips and knees and
shoulders and so forth because when you
have problems going on
in one location in your skeletal system
believe me it's going on every place
else and it's just because of the way
you walk or drive or whatever you're
getting more pain at one area or more
noise or more dysfunction in one area
but it's happening out everywhere
okay
i think that covers everything
i think you got it now dr wallach let's
go ahead and go to an email that came
through from
donna
so donna wants to know what supplements
can i take for trigeminal neuralgia it
is in my mouth going up to my nose on
the right side of my face
very difficult to eat when i try to eat
i have to try to keep the food on the
left side of the mouth
even when it burns i do get severe pain
and when it doesn't burn i get severe
pain thank you so much for the
information does she tell us how much
she weighs 125
and
62.
i bet she has blue eyes
maybe
five foot two eyes of blue isn't that a
song
it is
[Laughter]
okay yeah well trigeminal algae um this
has to do with osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing the fifth cranial nerve
okay and you get pain below the eye and
behind and
underneath the ear and of course it goes
up into the middle of the head and so
forth so this is why she's having all
this other stuff and a little bit of
this sore mouth she could also have some
squeezing of the ninth cranial nerve and
she's got some dysphagia because it has
to do with the mouth and the throat and
so forth
so um she's she's already got at age 62
she's got osteoporosis in the skull and
if she thinks about it
she may have had reduced amount of
ability to smell and i always like to
find out do they have any tingling or
numbness in their fingers or hands or
their feet
because this is another one of those
things that people get when they have a
diagnosis of ms multiple sclerosis they
get a lot of peripheral neuropathies and
tingling and numbness in their hands and
feet it's all due to osteoporosis it's
called squeezing the spinal cord okay
so
um we do need to get her on at
125 pounds
um get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meats no oils or
glutens
no wheat butter i know it's no sugar no
carbon or drinks even the that one's got
to go then i wanted to have one healthy
brain and heart peppermint get another
bottle of our saline with the five
cofactors not from walgreens but arsene
with five cofactors take three of the
selenium twice a day
then i wanted to have uh one bottle a
month of the msm so she can take um
three with breakfast through dinner time
that's gonna support and promote
maintenance repair cart legion ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
a vertebrae bone makes a bone itself
then i also wanted to have the collagen
peptides taken out so that no let me
back up take a scoop of that in her
drink in the morning and a scoop of that
in her drink in the afternoon i want to
have vitamin d three three of those
twice a day
okay
and um
then
she also should have one corn a month of
our count today so you take a half ounce
out of breakfast half ounce of dinner
time
and if she needs pain relief in a
particular joint or on her face
around her nose and under her eyes and
that kind of stuff she really needs some
pain relief she can use our cm cream and
trauma oil that will give her about two
to three hours of pain relief
um but the pain will go away as we
rebuild
her skull and it takes the pressure off
those
cranial nerves and so i want her to get
a hold of that the book
it's all in your head
and read it and there's there is
we cover 25 different diseases or caused
by osteoporosis
and of course we do have in that book
um a program a nutritional program so
she didn't have to remember all this
because i believe i repeat most of it uh
in in that book but any rate is one of
those things where
um it's one of those one of those things
where she's going to call us every
couple of weeks and give us the progress
or lack of progress reports but don't
forget it's essential for she and
everybody in your household get rid of
the bad stuff to maximize absorption
okay
dr wallach i just want to point out a
few things in this book
it's all interesting
so dr wallach goes into pretty
pretty deep detail with these
and even gives you pictures
for those of you that are visual
learners
um of
what is going on so that you have a
better understanding so i really
encourage all of you to go through he
talks about all the 12 cranial nerves
with description and pictures
um and it's
not very thick
so much i think it's like 27 pages
something like that
yeah so much information um
packed into
you're absolutely right
okay it's one of those things it's one
of those things rebecca where they don't
get taught this in school in medical
school
doctors do not know about all of the
diseases you get when you have
osteoporosis of the skull that's why i'm
the only one that's figured out what
causes ms multiple sclerosis
okay because again there's three or four
things going on there one of which is
osteoporosis of the skull
okay and then it's a bad diet
gluten and
and of course not taking the good stuff
taking away the good stuff like eggs and
cholesterol and stuff like that they
need cholesterol cholesterol is a good
guy not a bad guy your brain makes up 20
of the body's total
weight of cholesterol
and so and then of course diet you have
to deal with the diet so you can absorb
these nutrients okay
you can't just take the nutrient and
keep your bad diet because you won't be
able to absorb anything are they all
coming out and so the only people are
going to be happy are the bugs in the
septic tank okay
right
well i i think we're more important
about being happier than the bugs in the
septic tank dr wallick all right thank
you talking about the septic tank
earlier you had mentioned
earlier you had mentioned about
um
having any type of bowel issues
now one thing that i have found through
my practice as a health coach dr wallach
is people don't realize how often
they're supposed to be having a bowel
movement
some people think it's normal to have a
bowel movement every other day
okay well people should have a bowel
movement a minimum of once a day better
yet one twice a day one sort of like mid
morning and once um probably in the
evening between dinner and bedtime
okay that'll save you from having to get
up in the middle of the night
and so um yeah you want to consistently
have
um i think two bowel movements a day and
they should be
firm and they should be
a brown to a dark chocolate color okay
and
you can actually do a lot of tests
yourself you can go to a pharmacy and
get all kinds of tests without a
prescription
it only costs you a buck
okay to find out stuff you can go to and
get take one of your stool samples and
give it to a veterinarian tell us from
your dog and you want to see if there's
any parasites in there
okay
and
you know what i'm saying you'll save
yourself an enormous amount of money so
save yourself from having to go sit in
the waiting room with all these people
coughing on you with covet 19.
and so just use your brain a little bit
take your own bowel movement and take it
to your veterinarian and tell them it's
your dogs as fifi's
bowel movement here i want to see if
there's any parasites in fifi and so
it's it's an easy way very economical
because they don't have health insurance
for dogs and so they charge i don't know
what ten bucks or five bucks or whatever
it is for a stool sample whereas if you
go to the lab in the hospital it's gonna
cost you 250 bucks
now there's a big difference between
five bucks and 250. well there there is
a big difference and folks this is
coming from a veterinarian
who then became a naturopath doctor
so i know i can take my pet to the vet
and
it's 35 bucks for an office visit where
if i go to the doctor
i'm not walking out without paying at
minimum cash price 125.
there you go oh
hey
whatever works let's be empowered people
to take things into our own hands and
not be slaves
to
uh big pharma
so i don't know if i can say that but
yes you do
we treat our car we treat our cars
better than we treat ourselves
yeah absolutely
well we checked it we checked the air
pressure in the tower you know every
time we go to the filling station we
check the oil every time we go to the
filling station we check the antifreeze
in the radiator
we put high quality gasoline in we don't
put dirt from texas in our car and hope
there's oil in it we put good quality
oil in the car in the oil pan and so but
in humans we do everything the other way
we're trying to save money and you know
avoid
you know
any contact with any reality so
well
i'll just eat well i'll get everything i
need just my doctor says they eat well
eat the four food groups in the seven
food group pyramid well that's why we
have the industrialized world we rank
45th when it comes to
life expectancy we rank we go to 75 the
japanese go to 85.
10 years longer than us that's because
they eat like an asian and we eat like
people from
um england oh that's where we came from
we eat a sad diet dr wallach
i know i was sad every time
i stepped on the scale or every time i
had aches and pains or had to go to a
doctor's appointment and look at you now
and now
that's right now i i
have a happy diet i have a very happy
diet a very happy digestive system a
very happy body
um and and you don't have ms
i don't have ms yeah that's right
and and a lot of the symptoms that i did
have
are simple symptoms that
fall right in with that label of ms yeah
if you had gone to a neurologist you'd
probably said you had ms
well
i don't
i know whenever i had an mri and they
sent me to the university's neurologist
he thought that he was coming in after
seeing the mri to see somebody 65 70
years old and very poor health and at
the time i was only 30 years old wow and
i i was fit
i hurt like crazy but i kept it to
myself
and what he discovered just made sense
it's like okay that's
that explains why but they didn't give
me any solutions dr while like it was 15
years later before i found the solution
when i found you
i'm so thankful for solutions and i know
so many people are as well and
we have some more hands up dr well like
so let's go
tanya
tanya go ahead and unmute yourself if
you're able to come on camera with us
that would be fabulous as well
hi i'm sorry my camera doesn't work
no worries go for it we hear you loud
and clear my dear
um i'm one um
i'm uh sorry i'm 115 pounds i'm um 36
years old
i'm pretty healthy but i have uh clear
cell sarcoma cancer i had a tumor on my
leg that was removed in december
and i did not have any radiation or
chemo
i apologize what type of cancer did you
have
clear saw sarcoma
okay
was this in a muscle or the bone or
where
it was in the fat of my leg behind my
knee
okay so it was a soft tissue
okay
all right
anything else going on any high blood
pressure diabetes arthritis
back problems
nothing
okay um
36 years old how tall are you
five three
five three okay
all right well that's very simple
um
115 pounds
you want to get rid of all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat nobody ran oats
no sugar no carb and drinks even the
diet one's got to go 115 pounds i want
you to have one healthy brain and heart
pack per month a half a dose everything
twice a day except for the selenium once
you get another bottle of water to sleep
with the five cofactors not from
walgreens but arsene with the five
cofactors
so you can take three of those twice a
day
uh to help your immune system selenium
oh selenium okay
then i want you also to get our uh
killer biotic which has i think it's got
seven or eight mushrooms in it including
the rishi mushroom i want you to take
three of those twice every two miles a
month of our killer biotic and then ask
siri hey siri
tell me about some cancer research
with rishi mushrooms
is it effective
in treating cancer
and you'll get
you'll have to take a long time to read
all the information because rishi
mushrooms are legendary for supporting
immune system when people have a
diagnosis of cancer okay that's our
killer biotic take three twice a day two
vowels a month
and i also
want you to have
our btt 2.0 tablets now they are not a
replacement for the btt 2.0 powder which
is in the healthy brand hard pack which
is vitamins and minerals the btt 2.0
tablets support the immune system
okay but they also are anti-inflammatory
and pain reliever so once you take um
two three times a day that'll be one
bottle a month that's a big bottle so be
able to do that
and remember that the btt 2.0 tablets
are not a replacement for the powder
they you know they're an add-on okay
okay so let us know how it's going
and i'm sure they want you to come in
like once once every 30 days for a while
or something to check it out
now they have me come every like three
or four months to do an mri
okay they don't check anything else
except the growth of tumors
okay so let's say you know when you get
that follow-up but check out give us a
call let us know what's going on okay
okay what about uh germanium
well what do you want to use that for
um on one of your websites i saw that
you could use that for cancer
okay well it's a yeah it's an
anti-inflammatory and supports immune
system
and um
you know you can go to our list of um
uh herbal we got
uh let's see here we got 5 000 products
and we have we do have a book is called
let's pay herbal doctor
and so you can actually read that you
can read the information on details in
general germanium and other herbs
to support defenses against cancer
obtain that book it's um
let's pay herbal doctor okay
all right thank you so much okay tanya
all right tanya thank you so much you
know
dr wallach i had i i had one of um my
clients um text me and remind me that i
had gotten them on the 90 essential
nutrients plus super kb and killer
biotic and pre-biotics and they went
from having
one bowel movement per week to one to
two a day
and they feel fabulous
so okay that's a great great testimony
it's a great follow-up thank you for
sharing
absolutely let's go to the next hand
that is up
and uh is it marlena
marlena
yes welcome to a stock live you're
online with dr your wallet hi
for taking my call i'm inquiring for a
lady a 70 year old lady
that has hemoglobin alberta poly
thystemia
and that's where
it has something to do with uh too much
iron in the system
and of course um
you know youngevity products most i have
iron i'm i'm assuming
so how does that work for somebody that
that has that condition and it's
interesting her
sister doesn't have it
but she does and it's genetic so it's
something that has been triggered in her
system
okay how is she 70 how much does she
weigh 120 pounds
okay now there are no genetic diseases
my thesis is in the smithsonian
institute as a national treasure because
i proved there were no jack diseases so
if a doctor told her it was a genetic
thing
um that doctor she shouldn't go back to
that doctor find another doctor
there are no jaguar transmitted diseases
my thesis 25 million study
in washington university in st louis in
the center for college of natural
systems
okay
my thesis is in the smithsonian
institute as a national treasure brand
new in the box they sell for twenty five
thousand dollars each
okay this is unimpeachable information
yes i i
have listened to you many times and i i
understand that thank you okay but
there's no genetic diseases so she needs
to check out find another doctor okay
because he's giving him wrong
information probably wrong treatment
so
this can be caused by dehydration
okay so
the amount the percentage of something
goes up when the environment that liquid
goes down okay kind of thing and so
that's possible dehydration
also uh she could have um
uh like i say dehydration that's
probably one of the big things and we
don't know if she has high pressure
diabetes she didn't say anything about
that right
no
okay
well now basically what i would do here
is again get her off all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat no butter on
oats no sugar no carb enough drinks even
the diet one's got to go
i get on one healthy brain and heart
pack per month 120 pounds half of those
running twice a day except for the
selenium get an extra bottle of arsene
with the five cofactors not walgreens
but and have her take three twice a day
of arsenium she also needs
the
msm she could take three of those twice
a day that's one bottle a month that'll
support and promote mainstream pair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
ratios which includes the bone marrow
cavity where the red blood cells are
made
okay
she also needs the
collagen peptide to scoop with that in
her morning drink and a scoop of that
her eating drink that will also help
with the bone marrow okay and give the
bone marrow what it needs make it happy
and um
you know there's other data i'm sure she
had on her
physical and blood report and everything
but again just dehydration
um if she didn't have anything to drink
from the day before since the day before
and she wouldn't had a blood test
and so there's all kinds of room this is
a long-term thing she's had for many
many years
she has other family members that do
have it
um and and the thing is is
i i don't want to suggest youngevity to
her if if it had like the iron if she
has too much iron in her system and i
you know suggest a product that has
more iron in it that's what i'm
concerned about
okay well you have to understand there's
a reason why she's got quote too much
i'm assuming that means t-o-o too much
iron nervous system okay okay um and it
could be just dehydration it could be
um
where they live what's in their water
okay what's in their drinking water okay
it could mean something in the soil
where they get their vegetables from
all right
and so what i want to do is have a hair
analysis on the scalp that's going to
give us a lot of answers so the book
rare has been cured in chapter 10. it
tells you how to
cut the hair
how to package it where to ship it to
don't forget to put the check in there
because the lab won't run the test
without the check
and so that's going to give us a lot of
information
i want to know about 100 different
questions and the hair analysis will
give us an answer to each of those
hundred questions okay great that's a
really good idea thank you
okay so let's see let's say you know
it's going to take a couple of weeks to
get the data back from the lab so i'm
expecting to hear from you say in two to
three weeks okay
thank you
okay good to talk to you
all right thank you marlena
now dr wallach um darlene is writing in
and she has an important question she
wants to know how can she get off blood
thinners
okay
well that's why we have our formulas
instead of just you know
taking vitamin a and vitamin c and that
kind of stuff right
and so
you take our 90 cents of nutrients
appropriate for body weight
and you're going to get all the blood
thinners you need you know right now i
weigh 142 and i take three of the efas
twice a day and three of the fa pluses
twice a day which is part of what i'm
taking i'm taking two health advantage a
month probably
45 other products so two to three of
those twice or three times a day okay so
i'm taking
um
well over 215 nutrients
uh that's just the category but as far
as pills tablets and capsules i'm
probably taking
say maybe 300 a day
because they take three of these and
five of these and six of these and so
forth and so
um and so these the efas
and the fa pluses are two different
sources of essential fatty acids which
prevent blood clots i'm 83 years old
i've never had a blood clot
never had any bleeding anywhere and so i
can attest personally from my personal
experience
with literally millions of patients
every year and we're in 80 countries
and believe me if our system wasn't
working there'd be a big list of
complainers
yeah most definitely instead of people
writing in wanting to know
or wanting to
say how thankful that they are for
finding us finding you
so yes now dr wellick let's go to the
next hand that is up and that's barbara
barbara where did you go
she has a question in regards to
lymph glands and helping to drain them
let me see if i can find her here
barbara go ahead and unmute yourself
here i am
awesome thank you so much yeah i just
typed that question in the chat because
i didn't see my hand raised um because i
thought i'd push the button anyway dr
wallach thank you for providing this
format for us to get this great
information
and uh the lymph glands i've just
besides exercising and
for years i've been
like you stand in place and you bounce
without lifting your
heels i heard that was good for lymph
glands is there something in your
products also that
is there a particular reason why you're
asking that
i mean do you have some kind of i don't
know i'm just always concerned about
this that and the other
i hear you know i read about it and i
i don't know that i have the problem
okay all right what are you weighing how
old are you
uh i'm 75 i'm gaining on you fast
and uh i'm about 170 pounds
okay and
let's see here how tall are you
five six and a half
okay all right
so
any other issues any highlight pressure
diabetes you don't need medication
arthritis
i take no medications i rarely go to the
doctor
no prescription drugs
okay do you have any ring in your ears
or balance problems yes i do have
ringing i have tinnitus
okay then you have osteoporosis of the
skull
mastoidectomy and
the doctor's uh cleaning my ears every
time that machine i think well
never mind
but my master next to me what does that
mean uh in my ear the mastoid bone i've
had two surgeries on that
okay and you still have the tinnitus yes
that's because it has nothing to do with
the bone
ringing and removing the bones not going
to help you this is caused by
osteoporosis squeezing
the
auditory branch of the adrenal nerve
do you have any heart issues any afib
atrial fibrillation or tachycardia or
bradycardia anything like that
no sir
do you ever have any hiccups
um yes
okay that's the squeezing of the
recurrent nerve which is a branch of the
10th cranial nerve that controls the
diaphragm
so your 10th cranial nerve is also being
squeezed it's not unusual for you to get
hiccups or fast heart rate or irregular
heart rate and doctors think it's a
heart issue but really it's a skull
issue
you need to get a hold of the book
um it's all in your head
okay get ahold of the book it's all in
your head
and
look up these symptoms that you have and
guess what you're going to find the
answers in there but basically at 170
pounds once you get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils or gluten they'll leave it over
our brother notes
no sugar no carpet or drinks even the
diet one's got to go
i do want you to take two healthy brain
and heart packs for months two healthy
brain heart factors a month the photos
think twice a day it's 215 nutrients
right there
okay then i want you to get two bottles
a month of our msm
and take three at breakfast treatment
street at a time they're gonna support
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
bone itself including the skull
do you have any trouble swallowing
sometimes
uh no sir do you accumulate any mucus in
your throat and you're kind of
all the time because of
mucus well not all the time
but regularly often sometimes sometimes
yeah okay that's the ninth cranial nerve
being squeezed by the skull okay so
you've got two or three nerves being
squeezed by the skull yeah you need to
get a hold of that book
um you fell on your head
and then i want you to get the collagen
peptides put a scoop of that in your
morning drink put a scoop of that in
your evening drink that'll deal with the
bone marrow
uh autoimmune system and so forth as
well as the mechanics of the bone itself
in your skull
and then i also want you to have vitamin
d3 take three of those twice as two
bottles a month
and
i'm i'm um
let's uh
let's start there
thank you i will
will do bye-bye bye-bye
all right thank you barbara let's go dr
wallach to deborah deborah go ahead and
unmute yourself
you are on live with dr wallach
hi doc hi deborah
let me help you i have a friend of a
client who had her her teeth removed
many years ago and has dentures but she
didn't wear dentures her mouth became
more worn down and and she can't open
her mouth very wide
i don't have a lot of information on her
i think she's about five feet two inches
about a hundred pounds and i think she's
about 76 years old
okay
your jaw is part of your skull
jaw's part of your skull your upper
arcade is part of your skull do you know
if she had braces when she was a
teenager did she go to an orthodontist
anything like that
i don't know that she did
okay you need to ask her okay
um but at any rate because babies are
born with osteoporosis it's not an aging
thing okay it had to do with bad
nutrition somewhere along the line or
bad absorption or both okay
so she needs to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils glutens and we brought around
those no sugar no carbon or drinks
including the diet ones now at 100
pounds
five foot two that's about right but i
want her to have one healthy brain and
heart pack per month i get another
bottle of water slim so you can take six
a day two two and two or three and three
whatever is easier for her
and then i also wanted to have the
collagen peptides take a scoop of
breakfast drink scoop a dinner drink i
wanted to have the msm you can take one
bottle a month take three at breakfast
uh and three at dinner time and they're
gonna support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes your bone itself
i also want her to have one quart a
month of our cal toddy so you take a
half ounce of that at breakfast half
ounce of that dinner time
and
let's see here
um i think
it wouldn't hurt for her
to on her uh
tmj where her
um
joint and her jaw goes into her skull
okay she can put some of our same cream
and trauma oil there that's going to
reduce inflammation
and um
uh relieve discomfort and pain for two
to three hours okay so she can apply
that maybe two three times a day okay
and um but we should be able to rebuild
her so she'll be able to open and close
her mouth and so forth um and but she
also needs to get a hold of that book
it's all in her head so she understands
what's going on here because
she's already starting to get
um there's 12 pairs of cranial nerves in
the spinal cord
and they all get squeezed and so
um you get one or two things happening
for a while and then in six months to
two years later you get five or six
things happening then you wind up with
ms multiple sclerosis and then you're
starting to pay five thousand dollars
six thousand dollars a month
for for pharmaceuticals and and so on
and so she can stop all that from going
that direction by starting where we
suggested okay
okay all right thanks doc hey you bet
thank you deborah
all right thank you deborah
now dr wellick
i just want everybody to know how they
can get a hold of your information and
we're going to take a little bit of time
here
and make sure that everybody knows to
get back with the person that invited
them to this program because they cared
about you they wanted to make sure that
you received information that you're
hearing today for a specific reason and
that specific reason is to help you find
a better health journey or maintain
great health
your choice you can either be
preventative reactive
it's up to you
or you you know just
take what the good doctor recommends and
love life i know i do i didn't before
but i do know
so everybody get back with the person i
invited you if
by chance you found this program on your
own you can go to our website
askdoclive.com
we do have a store there and we also
have a contact us option where if you're
not quite sure
what you need in order for your own
health and what products to order you
can send us a question through contact
us and one of myself or one of my
certified holistic health coaches will
be getting back with you and helping you
find out what you need for your optimal
health journey
we do have a call team that is standing
by at 855.949.7234
that is for somebody who has never
ordered before please let me say never
ordered before
and have not spoken with somebody
previously
about any of our products or sent to
this program
by somebody specific so we want to make
sure that the correct person gets credit
for
you taking that step to invest in your
own health which invests in your future
now dr wallach kathleen has a question
she doesn't have audio or video so
she is 60 years old
196 pounds
five foot four
in 2004 she had gastric bypass
she wants to heal her gut as she has
constant diarrhea what can she do
okay so she had the bypass for the
weight loss right correct
okay
seven all right here we go
wow 18 years ago 18 years ago
okay and she's still at five foot four
i'd like to see her weigh like 140.
she's 50 pounds overweight
okay
she's 196 correct correct
okay so i wanted to get one meal a day
our keto shake
it comes in strawberry chocolate i
believe okay and it's one meal a day and
it's not an add-on it's a meal replacer
uh in in addition to the keto shake
strawberry or chocolate she can also
have one or two or rebound drinks okay
it has um 100 nutrients in it 75
minerals and 25 vitamins amino acids
and then i wanted to have two healthy
brain and heart pattern months start out
with two healthy brain heart factors
photos everything twice a day i want to
get two bottles a month of our msm so
you can take three at breakfast street
lunch dinner time and they're gonna
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes the bone itself
and
let's see here
oh collagen peptides one scoop of that
with a breakfast drink one scoop of
collagen peptides for their dinner drink
i wanted to have an extra quart of our
cattle toddy so she could take
196 pounds i have to take two
two quarts a month so she can take an
ounce of breakfast out to dinner time
and let's see here
um
i also wanted to have our ultimate
enzymes we called the gallbladder in a
bottle our ultimate enzymes she could
take two
like five or ten minutes for each meal a
couple ounces of water
and if she wants to
um do some laboratory work uh
she can get a hold of the book rare has
been cures go to chapter 10
uh collect some hair
um
it'll tell you how to box it up where to
ship it don't forget to put the check in
because the lab won't run the test
without the check and then in two three
weeks she'll get the results back and
then call us we'll walk her through what
you know the results is she absorbing um
the kind of thing is
is she high in toxic metals because
there's two charts one for toxic metals
like lead mercury and uranium i'm
getting so many people now
with high levels of uranium in their
hair where did that come from did you
live near a nuclear power plant yep well
that's where it's coming from they're
leaking so you need to tell them and
show them your hair analysis because you
know you you could have legal
um stuff going on here because they're
not correctly they should be catching
all that stuff before it gets out into
the atmosphere
okay
and so um so anyway um catherine i think
it's catherine right
uh kathleen kathleen i was close okay
kathleen
okay and so you know start there and
then give us a call do the hair analysis
and give us a call and we'll walk you
through this because this is all easily
doable and so you can expect to lose a
half a pound of two pounds a day
and on the key you don't have to wait
you know just go ahead and collect your
hair analysis
and
it's going to take a couple of days to
get the product to you and so don't wait
until you've been on the product for
three months to do the hair analysis you
want to do the hair analysis now so we
understand what's going on
and then in another three months you do
another hair analysis follow-up to see
if you've improved in all the places
that were bad
okay and so um i get excited about that
here analysis it's again the book rare
earthman shears chapter 10.
the book looks like this folks
well
not like that one it's the other big
white book
this one
uh there you go bear ears forbidden
cures you can go to drjwalic.com
and get your order directly from doctor
wallet
you know it's it's interesting dr
wellick that you mentioned um you know
uranium
is
well heather one of our co-hosts sent me
an article yesterday about a
decommissioned nuclear plant
that is not too too far from us that
they've opened for tours and i'm like no
thank you
and looking at research i mean that this
particular plant
put out more
um waste nuclear waste
and it's like 10 percent of the nuclear
that why waste
closed it down
that's what i'm thinking but yeah no i
don't want to go for you know
that one i'll buy i'll pass
so i love adventure but that's not the
one i want to take
yeah you might want to send an email to
their employees say hey you might want
to get a hair analysis
well and i actually know a couple of
people that used to work for them so
that really
kind of struck a note with me as okay i
need to reach out and see how they're
doing because it's been about 10 years
since i've talked
okay so i'm hoping they're still alive
let's go to the next hand that's up dr
wallach and susan
go ahead and unmute yourself susan
yeah
thank you dr wallach
i'm so glad and to have beyond these
products with you i'm i'm absolutely
delighted with my my progress i'm 5'3
pounds i've lost some weight and um
five foot are you
i'm 77. oh come here child
oh i'm planning to be one of those uh
septem you know
centenarians then that's the word
however i had a head injury this week um
i i was in the barn
and um i have a ranch and i fell and hit
the rototiller and i i cried i hit my
head and i went in for a cat scan
because the headache was all around is
there anything i can do it like the jaw
hurts and it still does i get pain
behind my left ear where the where the
rototiller hit me is there anything
extra i can do yes well there let me ask
you a couple of questions now before you
had this fall were you having any
vertigo or balance problems
no i
i i didn't turn on the light and so i
didn't see the rototiller
okay
yeah you need to speak to your kids your
employees what's going on here i i yeah
we got that
okay
and then let's see here
uh also
uh you need to
um
uh
oh
in addition do you have any ringing in
your ears do you have any tinnitus or
ringing
um just pain under the left ear and the
jaw and still have a headache it
happened three days ago okay but you
didn't have that pain before you had the
fall
uh
once in a while yes i did
yes okay
all right so you may have some
osteoporosis it's called not unusual for
someone 77 not directly related age but
77 is very common have osteoporosis
skull uh do you have your own original
teeth or do you have uh
implants or dentures they're all gone
they're all gone okay yeah you have
osteoporosis of the skull
did you go to a orthodontist as a
teenager for braces
no braces but i had very bad teeth as a
teenager i was always having problems
root canals you name it yeah okay yeah
so you had osteoporosis as a teenager oh
yeah
yep
okay
anything else how about pressure
diabetes
i have my left arm gets numb
often and sometimes my left hand gets
per
paralysis i literally can't move it
that's the approach to the skull
squeezing the spinal cord
yeah
there you go yeah so you have three
features of osteoporosis here so
um at
143 pounds
i want to
have you get off all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat bread around those
no
um
sugar no carbon or drinks even the diet
one's got to go
and then i want you to have
a 143 pounds and what you got going here
i want you to have two healthy brain and
heart packs per month photos saying
twice a day
only if you get our msm take two bottles
of that so you can take three with each
meal
and they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the rubber bay bone makes bone itself
including the skull and the vertebrae in
the neck and the back
and so on
um
and your hair color is going to come
back
okay gray white and silver hair has
nothing to do with asia it has to do
with the nutritional deficiency that
same nutritional deficiency
causes problems everywhere else in the
body and so i always ask people you know
are they you know they color their hair
said do you have any gray hair yeah but
i colored it okay well
now you're you're
using a hair color to over to hide a
nutritional deficiency okay it's funny
okay so here we go uh get rid of all the
bad stuff which we said then two healthy
brand heart packs two healthy
excuses two of the msm
uh so you can take three three times a
day uh the collagen peptides are scooped
but that with your breakfast drink and
scoop of that with your dinner drink
that's gonna help your bone marrow so
you can make nice white blood cells and
red blood cells and platelets and all
that kind of stuff
and it'll help your
disc between a vertebrae and help
rebuild your bones and your skull and
your neck and vertebrae and bones and
you're all over your body
and then you also need i'd get one quart
a month extra of the cal toddy's thing
take a half ounce with your drink in the
morning a half ounce of the cow tidy in
the evening time
and
again if you have any
um
hybrid
pressure diabetes anything like that you
said no no and okay good excellent so
let's go there and for energy i want you
to use our rebound or sports drink we do
have
great coffee we have decaf coffee we
have regular coffee if you're for if you
work a farm i i grew up on a farm so i
know what it takes to to work a farm
okay
and so yes so we do have um
organic coffee
uh we grow it we fertilize with our
bloom and minerals ourselves uh we do
the the roasting in our facility in
miami florida
and you know you can get a box of 24 of
these y cups
for 14
okay it's a lot cheaper than two cups of
starbucks okay which would cost you 25
bucks okay
not doing that okay so anyway um don't
forget the rebounder's first drink
and turn on the light next time
yeah i'm going to put a light in the
barn yeah we don't have one so i'm going
to put a light in the barn thank you
okay thank you we farmers got to stick
together
[Laughter]
thank you all right susan motion
detector
with that
light then you don't have to forget to
turn it on and off well dr warlock we
have about five minutes left so let's
go to mike and get mike's question in
here
mike go ahead and unmute yourself you're
on live with dr wallach
hey mike
let's try that again
there we go okay how are you doing doc
okay sir what's up how can we help you
well i i i had a hair analysis done a
few months ago and you know it's a lot
of great information i totally don't
understand everything about it yet but
the more i read it over and over the
more i'm i'm getting it but i had one
question on it like
well my toxic elements were all in the
low end and in fact only two of them
registered mercury and aluminum
uh the mercury is the highest one but it
still is in the low end so i guess i'm
okay if any of those are in the low end
it's not well if it well if they show a
spike on the chart if they show a bar on
the chart then i would take some action
okay so it says i've got mercury
and aluminum
okay
so let's back up some more here do you
have any health problems
not anymore
okay good
my medications i i've been on the
program for about a year now
okay what how many problems did you have
i had about seven medications i was
taking but i'm off everything now and
i've lost
50 pounds i'm i'm uh i'm five eight 185
pounds uh 62 years old
okay
so all right
heavier
okay did you have any arthritis any back
problem neck problems rain in the ears
blood pressure diabetes
i did have high blood pressure but
over a year's time my blood pressure
went down and and my doctor weaned me
off my blood pressure pills so okay good
okay excellent okay very good
and so right now um so tell me about
your chart for the the healthy minerals
okay
the healthy minerals are all
they're up in the reference range
the only one that's low and it's just
barely low is iron
and my selenium is high
so i because i've been taking a lot of
selenium okay good okay plus i take all
my vitamins and minerals and stuff i'm
on the protocol
i take the healthy brain and heart packs
i do it all
okay so those are two levels there the
iron
is the one that's on the low end okay
what you can do there is you know get
our plant derived minerals our liquid
plant derived metals our cherrymens or
something like that and go ahead at your
body weight you can go ahead and take
um
start out i'd say with an ounce twice a
day
the plant minerals added to your
existing program because obviously you
had good success
and that will uh will
increase your iron intake
and so let's go that direction and
then say in three months to another hair
analysis and see where you're at
and uh if it comes up in the range you
can drop it down to
one ounce a day instead of two you know
half ounce of breakfast half ounce of
dinner time
okay
and the only other question i had real
quick was in the in the additional
elements
i'm high
in the zirconium
and i was reading what zirconium is on
there
uh you know there's
the levels established in the reference
range element
and zocomian the circonium has not been
a well documented in humans
uh some of the sources that it can be
caused
is in antiperspirants
and maybe uh elements from dental
materials
so
i'm high in that and i was just
wondering is that something i don't use
in a person
what did you use or did you have a lot
of dental work
not really my teeth are pretty healthy i
mean i recently just did
uh have uh i had a cavity
from
30 40 years ago
in one of my one of my molars and it was
a huge they put tons of that silver
stuff in there but that tooth ended up
having a root canal and got a cap on it
before i did that right when i after i
did that but when you take in stuff like
zirconium you know it gets into your
bones and stuff and so it's there for
quite a while it doesn't just kind of
come and go kind of thing and so
let's let's kind of just you know
um move forward here and then say in in
three months time from now do another
hair analysis and see where you're at
okay okay
but i would i would for the iron i would
add the um definitely
uh add the uh extra plant minerals okay
i'm gonna boost my minerals i'm gonna do
that thank you doc okay
god bless you and thanks for the kind
report bye bye thank you bye
all right thank you and mike
you're like like a dream client or you
do what you're told and then you spread
the news and you
other people
because they see the positive things
going on in you they want them to and
you're just like a magnet so
it's it's wonderful watching him and all
of you that are watching this program
you can be magnets like that because as
we give our bodies minerals
we
just become positively charged that then
attracts people that are wanting to have
the energy and just that inner health
that flows out from us okay one thing
here before we go one thing before we go
please keep me informed on the
production status of this cd of today's
uh
okay i will
tell you okay
move it to the top of the list okay
thank you everybody thank you for
joining us with a stock live
sponsored by askdoclive.com
and
we are honored to have the one and only
dr joel wallick on with us every friday
at this time
go to askdoclive.com
and register to get your good foods bad
foods list and also be put on the list
so that you get notifications and
reminders of when our shows happen with
your special link to get on the program
with us on behalf of myself my
co-host ruth ellen sanchez
heather
bowen and dr judy reynolds and jonty
mccollier thank you for joining us here
on ask doc live bye for now love you
guys bye bye bye dr wiley
[Music]
see you soon bye